[music]
Hello everyone. I'm Albert Chun. I'm the
founder of AI Circle. Uh we're a
community of researchers, founders, and
operators who are advancing the frontier
of AI. And we partner with communities
and companies like Scientific because
they are uh ushering in the frontier of
physical AI. Um and and the reason why
we brought this panel together is
because
in the last few years, what we've seen
is the physical AI space go from science
fiction to science reality. You know,
we've we've seen it here today with uh
robots like at 1x who are um you know,
building bringing robots to every home
or we're seeing robots in industry and
you know they're folding our clothes and
washing our dishes. And I I think the
real question that we're not really
asking is do they do robots actually
understand what they're doing
and or are they just really adept at
pattern matching and will they collapse
when they encounter the randomness of
the real world and so I'm really happy
to invite our two speakers who really
live within this problem at opposite
ends of the spectrum. Uh first I'd like
to invite on stage Professor Woo from
Stanford um who helps really uh helps
the industry define uh what it looks
like for uh robots to understand. And
I'd also like to invite on stage Vasu
the chief AI and data officer at
Scientific because he's the one who
helps uh scale the data operations to
equip these robots to um work in the
real world. So, please uh give him a
round of applause.
>> Amazing. And um I'll just give you both
a moment to introduce yourselves a bit
and then we'll jump right into our
questions. Professor Wu, do you mind?
>> Okay. Um hi everyone. Um I'm Jing. I
work on uh computer vision and robotics
research at Stanford. Uh so we, you
know, build systems that help machines
that understand the world. uh reasoning
about objects and scenes, geometry,
physics, uh predict what's going to
happen and then also we work on robotic
manipulation that do robots that
interact with these objects.
>> Hey, uh this is Vasu. I uh work for
Scientific. I'm the chief AI and data
officer for Scientific. Scientific is a
data infrastructure pro data
infrastructure company that provides
highquality training data and validation
for the models and model providers. So
very happy to be here. Amazing. Thank
you. And so just to start us off, you
know, when we're looking at physical AI,
I'd love to ask you both uh what do you
currently see as uh the bottleneck? Is
it compute? Is it models? Um yeah what
what do you see as the bottleneck
profession?
Um well uh I guess you know unlike large
language models you know everything in
the physical world you know it's
actually much harder to have larger
scale data right it's like just unlike
digital world where you can generate
almost infinite data and users keep
producing and AI models can keep
producing data the high quality data
that you can produce in the physical
world is very limited it is also subject
to all these different physical
constraints you know extremely high
quality data may be very expensive so
what is the right combination of
different types of or different source
of physical data and how to combine them
to allow you to train a model that is
really able to scale I think is still to
be figured out.
>> Yeah. Amazing. Yeah. Thank you so much.
Yeah. So what I'm hearing from you is
the major constraint is high quality
data because the things that you need to
balance is what's high quality and
what's cost efficient in order to allow
these robots to Yeah. makes a lot of
sense.
>> Yeah. Uh I agree with professor Vu but
uh I would not add a nuanced argument on
what preventing us uh from having an
highquality data. Currently the data
ecosystem is fragmented. In physical AI
we are the data has to represent the
experience because the physical AI
interacts with the real world with the
real which creates lot of experience. So
the creating that experience
uh which is right now there is no
standardized way uh because there are
egocentric data there is a manipulation
data or the imitation data or the
sensory data but there is no common
standards defined. It is fragmented.
each one is doing the same uh in a in a
very siloed way and there is no constant
or there is no standardized eval or a
benchmarks that defines the data thing.
So these two things is what is going to
determine the high quality data that
accelerates the uh physical AI model
development.
>> That's right. Amazing. And you know,
Professor Woo, as as one of the most
cited researchers on the planet, you
know, I know that you've done extensive
amounts of research around the
shortcomings of um RGB video data and uh
talking about the importance of
multiensory data in terms of sight,
sound, touch. Um what what do you think
is the reason for uh the industry kind
of still being stuck on egocentric data
and and video data versus um you know
evaluating models based off of
multiensory data
>> right I think the nice thing or the
interesting aspects of robotics is you
have to deal with datas of very
different modalities and they're are
really heterogeneous right there's
vision uh there could be audio data
tactile data there could be like a lot
of these data about actions different
types of actions like the torqus that
you have on your joints and I think the
challenge is like you know unlike visual
data or maybe to some extent audio data
where you at least have a share format
right I think for other type of
modalities like tactile data you know we
have very different types of sensors and
the type of data they produce are even
in different formats right there's no
like PNG files just like images and for
action data as well because you have
different robots they have different
number of joints uh they're you know
controlled in different ways and if you
have ductress manipulation like hands
you you have different number of
fingers.
>> So what is the right way for us to have
a shared data format or data standard? I
think that would be a big challenge as
well.
>> That makes a lot of sense.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. So yeah, the professor Wu touched
upon the main point RGB is one form of
data which is primarily captures the
visual representation of the data. But
as you see the physical uh physical AI
has to work in the real world. The real
world experience consists of sensory
data which is and also it has to
estimate the weight the right amount of
the pressure and also it has to predict
the navigation to do perform a task and
it all needs to be done in a more
synchronized manner to produce a data.
So it not only gets all the sensory data
information along with the vision data
which is RGB but also it has to provide
the context that is at which it is
operating upon the enrollment that is
operating upon and so the temporal value
is also thing because usually when you
actually create a data it is always on
the snapshot but in a physical AI world
it is continuous. So the temporal
aspects of the data has to be
synchronized along with the sensory data
and that's what is going to determine
the quality of the data to train the
physical AI robots uh in the next few
things. So that synchronization on a
multimodel is the key uh for that
because our world is multimodel.
>> Sure that's very true. We do live in a
multimodal world. Um, you know,
previously you mentioned something about
the constraints of cost
um, in order to pursue highquality data,
but I guess with the industry pouring
hundreds of billions of dollars um, into
data and the infrastructure to power
physical AI in the next few years and
when cost is not going to be a
constraint, could you talk a little bit
about what it looks like to scale a
physical AI data physical AI data
infrastructure layer.
>> Yes. Uh so the first and foremost thing
is standardization of the the
multiensory data because now every
company defines its own schema and its
own uh evaluation mechanism. There is no
standard mechanism for standardized
mechanism for robots to learn or share
the experiences across the things. So
that one first thing uh if you solve
that the standardization is not an
impediment it is actually a compounding
factor. If you really see how the LLM
the the digital world has scaled is
because of the standardization because
of the standardization of the benchmarks
and the evaluation that's how the scale
happens. So this the first part is the
benchmark of this thing. Second, we need
to invest on the platforms, the
annotation platforms it does, right?
Because previously,
if you do an annotation of a cat or a
thing, if you wrongly annotate, the the
the impact is very minimal because it
wrongly classifies this thing. But if
you actually wrongly annotate a physical
AI world experience, the that it could
be a fatal. Okay. So that evolution of
the annotation platform with an human
expedition, human validation is very
very important. True.
>> And the third one on scaling the data
infrastructure is continuously investing
on benchmarks because benchmarks cannot
be static because it has to evolve over
the uh the evolving nature and the
evolving experiences of the benchmark.
these three constraints if you actually
work as an collaboration with academics
and the industry I think the scale we
have the impetus to scale uh into the uh
into the next level. So that's the kind
of a uh inflection point we are working
towards.
>> Yeah. So some of the researchers that
I've met over the years has told me that
uh one bad data point is worth 10
highquality data points. Yeah.
>> And to extend the conversation around
highquality data, um, I'd actually love
to touch on this. I think many people
look at data annotation as a bit
commoditized. Hey, just get a vendor and
label some data, QA it, and just get me
good data. Right? It seems like anyone
can start a data company, but in
reality, um, high quality data is
actually very difficult to achieve in
any length of time, especially at scale.
Um, and and Professor Wu, I'd actually
love to hear from you. I know this may
get a little technical, but I'd love to
hear from you maybe how you think
through high quality data when you are
working with a data partner.
>> Oh. Um, okay. There are multiple
aspects. Um, so you know there's good
data and bad data. There's high quality
data and low quality data. Yeah. And
sometimes you know uh I think people
sometimes confuse the concept as like oh
I have a fail attempt if the robot I'm
tiling up to the robot to do something
or I collect some data and it turned out
you know I the robot kind of failed you
know that's not necessarily a bad data
these kind of failure points can also be
good data because you actually learn
that you know how you can recover from
failures right so there's kind of you
know successes and failures they can
both be good but they're also bad data
you know bad data are you know when
you're collecting all very carefully
like like for example the cameras are
not calibrated. So then the data itself
doesn't allow you to accurately
reconstruct the scenes. You know, you
know these are kind of the issues where
you know people may often be not aware
of uh when they just like try to uh
massproduce or mass collect a lot of
data. Yes. You have to be really careful
in collecting uh high quality data of
both successful and fail examples.
>> Yes. Okay. So, one, I I I love that
because
yeah, what I'm hearing from you is that
data quality is not contingent on
whether it succeeds or fails at a task.
What high quality data is is if it gives
you uh a high level of signal over noise
to help you train your model.
>> I think that's right.
>> Which makes a Yeah, it makes a lot of
sense. Um and and to the point of high
quality data, I think this is what we're
always after, which is crafting the
golden data set. And so the the ever
elusive perhaps ever refining golden
data set like like what does an ideal
golden data set look like and this is a
a question for for both of you.
>> Yeah. uh yeah the quality and the
benchmarks are the most important
aspects of how fast we can train a model
and how reliable the model in the real
world is. So the the golden data set
it's an elusive problem because for us
it is uh the difference between a
language model and a vision model into a
physical model is we are trying to
define the physics of it which is got
all aspects of this thing. Whether you
are not only annotating an object or
annotating this thing but you are you
are actually saying why did it fail?
What are what are all the circumstances?
Was the pressure is good enough or is it
exceeded the minim maximum threshold or
the the wide varieties of these things
we need to capture to evolve around the
uh to arrive the golden data set for the
model to perform or not perform. Okay.
But it is also high domain specific. It
is a combination of robotic engineers
plus the actual practitioners who
actually practice in a manufacturing uh
setup or in a household task. How they
do actually the task and what kind of a
pressure they do? How do how do they
estimate a weight? How do they n how do
they predict the navigation? All of
these things has to be captured to
create a a probable scenario. So to to
put a point
It's not only supposed to tell what it
is, it's supposed to tell why it failed
so that it can learn from the real
experience and then you just train the
robots into that because that data
points that capture that becomes the
evaluation data set and with an expert
human validation you can actually do
that. Okay. There is another aspect of
evaluation and a golden data set is
synchronization of the multimodel. We
touched upon in this previous uh talk
question about the multiensory because
how do you capture all kind of
information with all sensors in a
synchronized way with a temporal way
that also defines the golden data set
for us. We are not there yet. We have
the basic building blocks but we need to
continually evolve that golden data set
for the physical evol.
>> That's right. Thank you so much. And
from your research perspective what what
do you think about when it comes to
building a golden data set?
>> Oh well I thought it would be you know
okay there are maybe a few different
aspects now. First and maybe the most
important is probably you want to
motivate yourself to build data sets for
tasks that you actually care about
people care about right? So instead of
like you know I think as a common
problem for maybe more like researchers
building data sets is like I look at my
robot and I was like what can I do or I
can do these five things and I build a
data set for these five different tasks
right but in practice maybe people care
about the other five things and the
things you can do is not something
that's very useful. Okay.
>> Yeah. So if you can select and design
problems right based on uh the task that
people actually care about that would be
great. Yeah. So that's actually okay
maybe a small advertisement that's the
motivation behind a large robotic
benchmarks that we built with fay at
Stanford called behavior that we
actually look at the daily activities
that people perform and try to collect
annotations for these activities and
then you can benchmark robot learning
algorithms.
>> Yeah. So one is task selection and
second is a high quality data
annotations. You if you selected these
tasks then how can you benchmark if your
robot is actually successfully cooking
dinner or do any of these things for you
right? How can you have the high quality
annotations on the task definitions on
the assets on the simulation
environments or in the real world? Um,
so yeah, so task definitions, data
assets. Uh, and uh I don't also being
comprehensive. So it' be nice to
actually cover a lot of different
activities, not just like a few specific
activities.
>> Yep. Yep. That makes a ton of sense. So
you you mentioned uh Feay Lee and um you
know you're a prolific researcher and
it's clear you care about problems that
you know other people care about here.
Um would love to hear from you how you
see the importance of academic and
industry relationships in advancing the
frontier
>> and this is for both of you. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, okay. Uh well it's kind of funny
cuz uh I think over the past few years
you know we always work with different
types of industry partners you know from
startups like scientific but also to
large companies like Nvidia, Google,
Meta, all these companies you've heard
of. Um but over the past few years it's
interesting that all these big companies
when they still want to do university
collaborations the the focus has shifted
from doing AI or just building models or
computer vision to doing physical AI
because for AI they're like okay we're
going to just use all our resources to
train Gemini so we don't need
universities anymore but then for
physical AI for uh robotics right the
problem is not solved yet there's still
a lot of research to be done before uh
scaling things up. Yes.
>> So they're like okay then why don't we
just work together on robotics. Yeah. So
I thought that's kind of interesting. Uh
uh so it' be nice to you know I think
the big company can still be very
helpful in providing resources and also
data collection as well but also compute
resources even if you want to design and
benchmark robot learning algorithms.
Yeah. So it'll be nice to see more of
those.
>> Yeah. Amazing.
>> Yeah. So we see the academic
collaboration is an essential part of
advancing the research labs. As you
rightly said there is no common standard
data schema. It is still fragmented.
there is no standard evaluation
framework. So that's where our research
collaboration with academic institute
will advance the field. I already told
the standards not just impending the uh
the innovation. It accelerates or
compounds the uh adoption because it
gives the credibility it gives the
standardization that is required and we
see that as an essential part of this uh
equation.
>> Yeah absolutely amazing. Um well I guess
with with just a minute left um want I
just want to take a time to to thank
Professor Woo and and Vasu for for
coming on stage and sharing with us. Uh
again, we're we're so happy to be
partnering with uh companies like
Scientific who craft these uh research
partnerships to help us advance the
frontier of AI and and help us think
through some of these bottlenecks like
data, help us define what good looks
like through golden data sets and um
yeah, help usher in the the new frontier
of physical AI. So, thank you all so
much.
>> Thank you for the opportunity. Thank
you. Thanks. Amazing. Thank you. Thanks
so much. Appreciate you. Thanks. Thank
you.